finally we have a pick from drew's
little yellow book yes that's right
it is
my personal curation that i work with
everyone on the show with because i
think that if i was a professional
curator i would be happy so we refresh
it every single week we're very
thoughtful about it we do all the pics
ourselves and this week i'm excited
because i did a social post about this
and it just brings me to nostalgia city
i just seen
and has anyone seen spider-man here i
hear it's so great it is so good and it
is about the power of three
and which takes me back to the best time
a
you know girl could ever have and that
was being one of
three with the charlie's angels so
flower beauty made this flower beauty x
charlie's angels palette which is now
available exclusively with our beauty
partners at cvs and you can get it on
flowerbeauty.com
and it looks like a dvd and there's all
these treats with it and uh the colors
are like angel's eyes starfish
which is what tom green called me in the
movie i liked it so much i married him
speaking of there's the chad dylan good
morning angels independent women hey
guys i will never forget being in the
trailer and we we heard the demo from
destiny's child come in i just heard
that song the other day and i was like
drew
that's you
you get a shout out and that's what does
that get does
with my girl drew cameron d and destiny
charlie's angels come on and they were
three women yes they were i mean being
in you know your early 20s and trying to
produce the charlie's angels movie and
hear destiny's child songs coming in it
was just
it was the best time that's so amazing
in the world was it it really was it was
you know we spent
five years making two of those movies
they each took two years to make we
trained we toured the world we became
best friends
you know it was us three girls and there
is something about that trinity that
trio that
triangle that's unshakable and um yeah
so this feels very meaningful for me to
be a part of and put out in the world
right now so if you want to get in touch
with your inner little superhero
go to cvs or the flower beauty website
and get your flower beauty x charlie's
angels palette it's time for a pick from
the little yellow book which is my
personal guide to things that i really
want to share with you i can't contain
it okay today it's an incredible list
created by the strategist they have 28
gifts under 50 dollars from hispanics
and latinx owned brands there's noche
clara cactus soap by no palada an
exfoliating bar with active charcoal oh
i'm there for that and of course the
versatile beauty blender created by
incredible makeup artist rhian silva
she's been on the show it's now
recyclable get the full list on our
website from the strategist one of my
faves
i just want to thank machine gun again
for also being a man who reveals his
feelings
and a gentleman
um who is putting something so fantastic
out in the world he's such a trendsetter
and changing you know what men do with
their fashion and flair and expression
so his lacquer company undone lacquer
as we heard about you know because he's
looking to
have a name that is less than perfect we
are all undone it's very sexy too um and
this is just incredible this product i
applaud him for putting it out into the
world he has a giant platform people are
following what he does
it's exciting when people take this
artistic license and do things that
include everybody and i'm so excited to
make sure to promote this fantastic new
brand that he has put out into the world
as we got into much and many discussions
at the core also of what we wanted to
present to everybody is this wonderful
company that he started and i'm just so
excited for this launch he's such a
trendsetter and just you know
gives the license for us all to play and
i just could not applaud this launch
more so get your undone lacquer
and play
[Music]